there were some initial concerns about
the settings of EA's next battlefield
game I'm Dave and welcome to a 1914 news
update following last month's news that
eh Studios boss Patrick soderlund
initially rejected dices pitch battle
field 1e a CFO Blake Jorgensen said
today but there were concerns the
company's young audience didn't even
know World War One happened one of the
reasons why söderlund originally
rejected dices battlefield 1 pitch was
because he thought trench warfare
couldn't be fun but World War one
offered much more than that and once
developers presented these ideas to EA
the project got the green light I think
what people don't understand about World
War one is the technology shift that
went on during the war people started
the war on horseback and ended the war
with airplanes and tanks and battle
ships and submarines and that's a huge
opportunity for us to be able to do a
video game around jorgensen also
mentioned that there was a huge
geographic opportunity for Battlefield
ones content since World War one took
place all across Europe and northern
Africa it appears that people are indeed
interested in a world war one
battlefield game the games announcer
trailer is now the most lights trailer
for anything on YouTube Jorgensen said
that this fixed to the excitement that
exists around the game even if it might
not necessarily be indicative of future
sales battlefield one launches on
october 21st though people with an EI
origin access membership or those who
pick up the deluxe edition can get it on
October 18th additionally a beetle will
be held sometime before launch in other
news about the game EA will broadcast a
live stream of a 64 play a match at e3
2016 as part of the company's EA play
event so what you think about the game
setting are you excited to go back in
time and fight through World War 1 or
were you hoping for a more futuristic
look and maybe a battlefield 2143 let us
know in the comments section below or
find me on Twitter at irregular Dave and
for all your gaming news stay tuned to
gamespot com
you